hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
tech channel of the week number 11 uh
the original mkbhd video series and uh
this tech channel of the week uh like i
said number 11 and also you can get this
background at the link in the
description i think it's pretty flashy
or you can follow me on twitter where i
always let you guys know when i change
my background anyway let's get right
into uh the tech channel of the week
which is imac carly and uh this is a i
guess a relatively new channel actually
uh the channel was created or started
making tech videos uh right around the
same time that i did
and um since it's the tech channel of
the week number 11. i'm just gonna give
you guys a quick tour of the youtube
channel
so first thing you'll notice is it's
running uh carly's running a youtube 2.0
layout right now got a nice little apple
logo on the right hand side and i'm just
going to scroll down and show you guys
basically what i like to call
i guess what hits you like right when
you when you visit the channel you know
there's the specs of the channel so
you'll go ahead and see there's uh
approaching 20 000 channel views
uh joined january 3rd 2009 so again
about six months making tech videos on
youtube and has 804 subscribers right
now
and the three links that i'm going to
throw you guys in the description are
number one uh the link to her youtube
channel which is imac carly
and number two the link to our website
which is i'm at carly dot tk
and number three which is actually kind
of hidden down here if you didn't if you
guys didn't see this is twitter dot com
slash imac carly so she does have a
twitter uh so basically what this
channel is is a combination of hardware
and software which is kind of like what
i do
and uh on this channel uh the most
recent video is a direct upload test
from the envy uh actually the envy touch
and uh there was an envy touch unboxing
on this channel which was actually
really uh coincidental because someone i
know was uh considering getting an envy
touch and it was like really like spot
on with the timing and everything so i
was able to show them that unboxing
video so i'm gonna go ahead and grid
this here
uh you can see there's a combination of
accessorizing and more that'll be
software and the richard solo 1800
review or the 40 things around the room
video which is very popular these days
uh is a hardware video on the rocket
fish mouse versus the mighty mouse that
whole kind of stuff
so there's definitely a mix of hardware
and software on this channel so if you
guys want to check it out i'm just going
to go ahead and go to the most viewed
section here which is generally where
you see the kind of videos that catch on
that get the channel more popular if you
go to my mostly videos you'll see
two tutorial videos which are the safari
4.0 and the windows themes video which
both pass twenty thousand views
uh so this is uh i'm at carly's most
viewed videos
hardware hardware hardware software
software software which is pretty pretty
awesome that there's such a great
variety on this channel so if you guys
you know you guys don't necessarily have
to have a mac to relate to this channel
uh you know a lot of a lot of mac
related channels like uh you'd think the
name i'm matt carley if you've ever
heard of the show icarly and her name is
carly and she has an imac so it makes
sense but anyway a lot of the uh the mac
related channels kind of require you to
have a mac to do the things on the
channel
but this having some hardware stuff on
here actually spices it up and and
people who don't have a mac can still
use the things that are on this channel
like that the headphone reviews and the
richard solo 1800 etc so yeah i'm just
going to go back to the main channel
here this is basically um basically the
overall rundown of this channel if you
guys want to check it out the like i
said the links will be in the
description uh she's a subscriber i
believe i mean i should kind of check i
guess but
i'm a subscriber if i'm at carly and uh
that is basically it so uh help us help
her get to a thousand subscribers we can
probably do that guys
and uh check out this channel and watch
a few of the videos on this channel see
what you like anyway thanks for watching
this tech channel of the week number 11
and uh if you like that wallpaper again
i tweet out every time i change my
wallpaper from those hd wallpaper sites
and uh that is it guys thanks for
watching peace